hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions you are waiting
for your flight to Seattle and to pass
the time you call three friends in
Seattle you independently ask each one
if it is raining all three of your
friends say yes it is raining but each
friend lies with probability one over
three and tells the truth with
probability two over three can you solve
for the probability it is actually
raining in Seattle this is adapted from
an interview question that was asked at
Facebook pause the video if you'd like
to give it a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to answer
this interview question
[Music]
so we can get started by drawing a
probability tree one branch will be if
it actually is raining in Seattle now if
all three friends are telling the truth
they will all say yes this happens with
a probability of 2/3 for each friend and
since they're independent we can
multiply the probabilities to get 8 over
27 the other branch will be if it's not
raining in Seattle now if all three
friends are lying then they will also
all say yes each friend lies with a
probability of 1/3 so we end up with the
probability of 1 over 27 that all three
are lying we now want to calculate the
probability of each branch but there's a
problem we need to know the probability
that it rains in Seattle this
information was intentionally omitted
from the interview question unlike a
textbook problem or all the information
is given to you the interviewer wants to
know can you do more than solve textbook
problems I'll mention that many people
thank me for covering such problems
saying mind your decisions videos have
helped them get high-paying tech and
finance jobs so what you're supposed to
do at this point is ask the interviewer
for the probability the interviewer
might tell you that it's 25% or they
might tell you to solve for the general
case that the probability of rain is
equal to P so let's solve for the
general case write the probability of
rain is equal to P so the probability
that does not rain is 1 minus P we can
now calculate the probability of each
branch by multiplying the respective
probabilities the top branch will be 8 P
all over 27 and the bottom branch will
be 1 minus P all over 27 the chance that
it is actually raining is the
probability of the top branch divided by
the sum of these two probabilities now
we can also rewrite these probabilities
in terms of conditional probability this
will allow us to express the answer a
little bit more formally using Bayes
rule the probability that it's actually
raining given that all three people say
yes will be determined by
this formula we substitute in the values
that we calculated and then we're going
to simplify notice that the twenty
sevens cancel out and were left with the
formula 8p all over 7p plus one and
that's the answer I think this is a
wonderful interview question many
applicants will have the technical
skills to solve a probability problem
like this but how many will have the
courage to ask for missing information
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube thanks for watching and
thanks for your support
[Music]